[Music]
what's up guys i'm kbhd here can i just
say right off the bat thank you for an
amazing 2018. like at the end of the
year it's kind of like this reflective
time when we look back at it and looking
back at this year
it was kind of incredible for tech
for videos
and just in general so so thank you for
that so this video is my look back
i actually started the year last year
with a goal of making 100 quality tech
videos and my own definition of quality
may be different from everyone else's
but that was the goal the year before
i'd made 96 you don't want to make more
videos to the detriment of the quality
but this year i think we made better
videos and the number we ended up with
was
99
so
we were close but hey it was better but
i think in those 99 videos
we got a lot done
the year kicked off with january and ces
of course where we got to play ping pong
against a robot we shot the first
episode of autofocus out there as well
with the tesla model 3 in california by
the way i think it's a great name for a
series and every episode since then has
had custom intro with the vector art of
the headlights of the car so in case you
didn't notice nice touch then i also
joined ethan and gila on the h3 podcast
which was fun then there was february
vin and brandon hopped on board and we
also launched a new merch line with a
core of t-shirts and we've added a
couple of things since then that i think
have turned out pretty well in march i
hopped on star talk and i got to
interview neil degrasse tyson i had a
lot of questions but we used all of our
time on my first one that is based on a
principle of physics discovered by a
physicist who had no interest in
medicine so in april we ended up in
portland to make my favorite episode of
dope tech of all time with the motorized
precision robots and that month i was
also nominated for and won the shorty
award for creator of the decade which i
mean the trophy sits back there
it's still that's absolutely insane so
again
thank you then in may i did a q a with
peter mckinnon where he got me to try
coffee for the first time then i shot a
commercial with under armour and steph
curry i'm not a good actor though so i
played myself in that commercial then in
june auto focus episode two was with
apple carplay
and the lamborghini aventador pretty hot
car but of course not as hot as the
wings i ate with sean evans on hot ones
yeah all right in july i did a q a with
ijustine and unboxed an 18 year old
laptop on her channel and you may have
noticed we also got the cinema robot
from the dopetech episode in portland it
is in the studio now it is absolutely
ridiculous and then in august i hung out
with and interviewed elon musk about
tesla and we toured the factory right
before he went on the joe rogan podcast
in september i lived with a supercar for
a week thanks to acura and it became
autofocus episode 3 my favorite yet and
i was easily the most i've learned about
cars and about shooting car videos then
we went full tech tober mode in the
busiest month of the year and made 11
videos in one month which i think is
probably the most i've done in a super
long time and i officially at this time
switch the videos to the two to one
aspect ratio you see now so a little
wider than 16x9 but it's worked out
pretty well and then i also attended and
accepted a streamy award for 2018's
creator in science and education and i
joined the joe rogan podcast didn't
smoke though then in november i got hit
by a truck in my car so uh that's now
under repair it's going well though it's
getting started and then december we
completed the massive blind camera
smartphone test with a bunch of
youtubers reactions to it all by the way
they're all great channels and really
good friends so i'm gonna link them all
again below you should subscribe and
check out their videos they're all
awesome and then i was in youtube rewind
and marquez brownlee it is now
officially the most disliked youtube
video
of all time ever we made history and
then we finished up with the smartphone
awards which the companies that won
those awards have actually requested
their trophies so i'm now packing them
up and shipping them to them so over the
course of those 12 months you guys
watched over 1.5 billion minutes of
mkbhd videos which is over 3 000 years
of human life
watching
videos
i don't know at least it was crispy
though and then this whole time even
when it's not that warm i've been
playing ultimate frisbee pretty much
constantly i played for the club team in
new jersey called gsu garden state they
all know my middle name i played for the
pro team in new york called new york
empire in the audl we had a pretty solid
season and we ended it by dethroning the
number one seed in the division to go
represent the east and the final four at
the championship weekend so that was
pretty solid and then i also managed to
help win a beach national championship
with a team called humil swag shout out
to tim brown so pretty good you're a
frisbee too i would say yeah weird flex
but okay
fair anyway as you can tell it was a
pretty damn busy year um and it kind of
never ends because tech is just
constantly coming out but i think me
plus the team of three we did a pretty
good job covering a decent variety of
stuff but i expect that variety of
things to widen even more again in 2019
and also there were many things in this
past year that i wanted to cover that we
didn't quite get to even that we might
start with in 2019 stuff like the mac
mini because i was sort of buried in
between ipad pro and all the other apple
stuff things like the surface laptop too
my favorite windows laptop ever it's all
matte black everything
a lot of great things going for it this
is the longest time i've ever used a
windows laptop but we just get to a
video about it this is the google home
hub that came out with a bunch of the
other google stuff that we're still
finishing reviewing uh there's the
gaming phones we didn't get to review
the rog phone and the razer phone too
separately but the point is there's a
lot of text still we didn't review maybe
leave a comment below of what you want
to see reviewed in 2019 even if it came
out in 2018 that you're still interested
in i have a feeling i kind of know what
those things are but let me know but i
just want to say i'm i'm really looking
forward to 2019 bigger and better things
of course are expected for tech and then
for the videos about that tech there's
already some things planned that i can't
tell you about there's already some top
secret video that's been shot and edited
but that i can't share with you yet
that's coming next year and maybe just
maybe we'll actually get to upload 100
videos also so to all the people that
have watched and supported in this
incredible year shout out to all of you
thank you especially those who were here
from before this year and to all the new
people hi even bigger shout out to the
first couple hundred people that hit the
join button and subscribed and joined
the club to the mkbhd channel without me
even talking about it in a video at all
that's been amazing to see and we sort
of have things planned for content and
extra perks and things for that for now
those of you get like a cool little
badge but there's more plans so thank
you to those of you who are already on
board so basically the point here is
2018
the past year has been incredible
uh tough act to follow but i think 2019
with what we have planned uh and with
you guys on board is going to be even
bigger and better than the last
thank you for watching have a happy
holiday and an awesome new year
catch you on the other side
peace